[Musique]
l'attentât qui a été commis contre le
domicile de jean marie le pen président
du front national ce matin le front
national c'est un mouvement
d'extrême-droite et bien c'est l'un des
plus violents enregistrés ces dernières
années à 16h50 ce matin donc une
explosion d'une violence tout à fait
inouï a détruit plusieurs appartements
de la ville voire de la villa poirier
dans le 15e arrondissement de paris où
se trouvait le domicile de monsieur le
pen la violence de l'explosion de
l'explosion tend à donner raison à
monsieur le pen lorsqu'il dit c'était un
attentat pour tuer alain rodier sur
place
pas de décision
un immeuble de cinq étages en partie
effondré des centaines de vitres brisées
sur les maisons voisines des voitures
endommagées et seulement six blessés
légers dont un bébé sauvé
miraculeusement par son matelas après
une chute de 15 mètres c'est
l'incroyable bilan de cet attentat
aujourd'hui avec ses 12 appartement
dévasté l'immeuble est condamné une
trentaine de personnes devront se
reloger d'après les experts seule une
bombe d'au moins cinq kilos de dynamite
déposé au quatrième étage sur le palier
de l'appartement occupé par monsieur le
pen a pu provoquer un tel résultat est
pour le leader du front national
l'importance de cette charge la plus
grosse qui est explosé depuis longtemps
témoigne une volonté criminelle
est évident que cette explosion cet
attentat visait de toute évidence à tuer
tuer aveuglément sauvagement et que
c'est un don du ciel on peut le dire si
ce résultat n'a pas été atteint ce n'est
pas la première fois que vous êtes
victime d'un attentat risqué le
troisième jeu c'est un record peu
enviable alors quel est votre sentiment
écoutez je ne peut relier sa queue à
notre congrès national dont dont le
thème était justement la sécurité des
français et la lutte contre le crime
alors je pense que c'est un
retour de manivelle des criminels ce jeu
peut l'interpréter comme ça
[Musique]